et en ce 24 décembre bien il sera
d'abord question du train de noël vous
allez avoir un aperçu de l'ensemble dans
quelques instants
pourquoi nous aurons des petits papiers
à la main parce que c'est extrêmement
compliqué oui partant de bruxelles via
lille arras et amiens pour paris qui
sera sa destination
notre train de noël sera conduit par
jean nohain et toute son équipe
habituelle qui proposeront des
distractions et des jeux pendant tout le
parcours c'est à dire à l'intérieur du
train aux voyageurs ces voyageurs et
bien ce seront essentiellement et des
grands-pères belge qui partiront en
quarts de bruxelles pendant que se
déroulera à paris marie-claude avec
leurs petits enfants et ils arriveront
de cette façon à lille mais par
anticipation si vous voulez bien nous
allons imaginer que nous sommes le
samedi 24 décembre et il est 13h45 c'est
à ce moment là que le train de noël
prend le départ de lille voilà le départ
est pris je dois ajouter que le
réalisateur c'est à dire alexandre
tartas et assurer la participation d'un
hélicoptère passe était extrêmement
compliqué comment vouliez-vous pouvoir
suivre le spectacle à bord du train sans
un relais absolument indispensable donc
tout cela se déroulera dans le train et
nous allons de ce fait arriver
maintenant à arras
après le journal télévisé de 20h 15 et
le départ des jouets des cinq mille
colis de la rtf abords du coche d'eau au
mouillage à la concorde
pierre tchernia et alexandre tartas nous
gratifie dans une ambiance très
britannique du noël de sherlock holmes
ensuite une visite aussi inattendue que
sympathique celle de jean gabin la
distribution des jouets continue mais à
21h10 yvan audouard arrive à l'écran
avec sa pastorale qu'a réalisé jean prat
et à 21h55 c'est la balançoire de
balthazar de denise glaser réalisé par
pierre vial est avec danielle darrieux
et charles aznavour
et bien suivant les usages nous avons
terminé cette nuit de noël avec la messe
de minuit
et comme chaque dimanche c'est avec les
émissions religieuses que débutera notre
programme le matin à 10 heures tout
d'abord le service protestant en
eurovision depuis brême puis à 11 heures
la messe de noël dans la neige et qui
sera illustré par un film de jean marie
drot emma d'amour
eh bien il est temps maintenant de
quitter merlimont les animateurs et les
invités de cette émission pour rendre
l'antenne à paris qui va vous proposer à
14 heures précises la télévision
scolaire
je vous rappel lors de vos actualités
régionales 19h15 et également que demain
sur la seconde chaîne de 14h à 14h30
vous pourrez suivre le magazine du
mineur bonne après midi à bientôt
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs vous
allez assister cet après midi et ce soir
aux premiers programmes diffusés par la
seconde chaîne de télévision monsieur
robert bordas directeur général de la
radiodiffusion télévision française vous
parle
eh bien nous y sommes les dates sont
tenus voici le premier spectacle de la
deuxième chaîne
le programme que nous vous proposons
n'est pas celui d'une journée ordinaire
de la seconde chaîne
en effet les émissions que nous allons
vous présenter ne sont pas
nécessairement complémentaires de celles
diffusées dans le même temps par les
émetteurs de la première chaîne nous
commençons par du côté de la musique